voilà mais c'est là un petit bravo quand
même j'ai des pertes toujours plus fort
on suppose
je vais pas un extenseur
une force du double voyez-vous qu'un
dans une force de 275 kg et bien
messieurs dames ça me fait toujours
grand plaisir fige doivent ils sortent
un effort qui viennent contre les sk
quelques exemples très fort qu'il devait
venir contrôler j'ai eu des tas de
souvenirs avec butler comme vous
l'appelez jour les boulangers une porte
et les pois et laure douce et ses
grosses boules aux vans et mon histoire
se passe en 1938 et un tout petit garçon
et mon père était très très fort pas
pesé 114 kg me lavais poignet en mer que
vous devez connaître ce genre de
performance que faisait les athlètes
toit de 20 kilos qu'il fallait prendre à
la pince par le petit rebord et nous
étions faucher je me souviens c'était à
dimanche
papa m'avait emmené nous marchions un
pied place de la bastille où nous étions
tout à l'heure et puis il y avait cet
attroupement devant un homme comme vous
qui se plaît donc joue la boulange il
avait posé un billet de 1000 francs ces
grands billets qu'il y avait avant
guerre pendant et des serviettes avoir
papier peu de moyens cet effet normes et
il disait mille francs mille francs
mesdames et messieurs mille francs à
celui qui portera ce poids à la pince et
alors il s'adresse à tout le monde vous
monsieur ou monsieur pearson ceux qui
essayaient ne pouvait pas y arriver et
il va mon père est oui et vous le gros
c'était la seule chose qu'il fallait pas
dire à mon père ça le rendait fou à bas
le groupe ne supportait pas il le regard
lui fait pourquoi pas aller voler tout
le monde riait de voir cet homme qui
n'était pas toujours ne va pas été pas
de jeunes s'approchait de ce poids de 20
kilos en plus mon père était blessé de
la guerre de 14 il avait une jambe qui
était pratiquement morte alors les
s'approche du bateleur et lui fait je
veux bien essayer mais ma jambe est
morte
est-ce que je peux m'appuyer sur vous
comme ça il ya les cellules pression de
l'autre mon père sa fille une et l'asie
des types qui commençaient à fuser dans
tous les coins j'étais furieux furieux
je lui envie des coups de pied droit de
la bouche à tous ceux qui a agressé un
peu mon père papa se penchent me fait un
petit clin d'oeil prend le poids de 20
kg essaie de soulever 26 de sa tête il
dit maintenant les mille balles vite
fait tout le monde applaudit on a pris
les 1000 francs et laâyoune grand geste
de mon père il a appelé à taxi taxi au
parc des princes nous avions un match de
football qu'on voulait voir eelv on ne
pouvait pas y aller vous allez passer
d'argent à voir on a pris un taxi pour
aller voir ça vous m'avez après tous ces
souvenirs lors il se comprend sa marque
pis ce sera ta négoce
oui mais ça n'a plus aucun rapport
maintenant c'est une merveilleuse
brasserie alsacienne
à l'époque c'était un café un bistrot
alors il y avait un concours d'amateurs
qui avait lieu tous les lundis la scène
était par ici la place de la cuisine
c'était beaucoup plus large
et puis moi j'habitais arrêter là
boulevard richard lenoir avec mes
parents chez mes parents et un jour mes
copains m'entraîne en lisant bien bien
bien on rigole c'est formidable ya un
concours d'amateurs au bistrot arrêté je
viens et puis on s'installe on écoute
les chanteurs et puis au bout d'un
moment le présentateur commence à dire
et maintenant nous avons philippe aller
arrive à sion il m'avait inscrit ces
imbéciles je suis pas chanteur vraiment
lâchés au conservatoire de comédie je
n'avais jamais chanté de ma vie je
pressais les pantalons dans la journée
pour gagner un peu d'argent et vraiment
je n'avais aucune idée parce que c'était
que nous tour de chant as tu des gongs
sud d'hébron sa seule chose qu'il
fallait pas venir gens devant moi je
vais y aller j'ai été chantée qu'est-ce
que j'ai chanté à ce moment là je serais
incapable de m'en souvenir
ou peut-être si une chanson stupides et
ridicules il s'appelait le chapeau à
plumes fusée howell à une prime plein
plein plein plume peux plus me plaît
plume à son chapeau au est le sens plus
en plus bleu me plaît plus plume peuple
aime comme un oiseau et le côté
intellectuel de la chanson c'est
formidable et la fin du concours arrive
et nous nous trouvons à égalité avec un
monsieur qui s'appelait gazelle gazelle
je n'ai revu par la suite très souvent
c'était un chanteur style le chanteur
d'opéra et ya rien de plus dangereux
dans les concours d'amateurs que les
chanteurs style opéra avec des voix
extraordinaire et on se trouve donc à
égalité tous les deux gazelles et moins
alors y avait les partisans de gaz n y
avait des partisans de philippe c'est en
1940 47 et le présentateur et l'idée
géniale liambas y voter puisque philippe
nous a amusé on va demander maintenant
de nous charmer et puisque monsieur gaz
elle nous a charmés on lui demande et
nous amuser gaz elle n'a pas été drôle
et moi j'ai chanté alors à ce moment-là
ce qui m'est venu à l'esprit jeu
avec toute la puissance vocale que je
pouvais donner et j'ai gagné le concours
mais ça c'est pas très très bien terminé
parce que les partisans de gazelles ont
commencé à rouspéter les miens aussi les
miens étaient un peu plus jeune j'ai eu
une bagarre épouvantable place de la
bastille le car de police est arrivée on
a embarqué tout le monde et j'ai passé
ma nuit à essayer de libérer mes
camarades car j'étais seul à avoir une
carte d'identité
quand je m'étais fixé un but le but
était le suivant partir de la place de
la bastille est arrivé à l'opéra parce
qu'à l'opéra il y avait l'olympia alors
j'ai fait tous j'ai repris le boulevard
beaumarchais à droite pas craint j'ai
été je suis pas j'ai dû faire cinq ou
six cents que six apparitions n'a pas
craint alors au fur et à mesure que je
montais ce boulevard beaumarchais que
j'arrivais sur la république que
j'arrivais sur la place de la bastide
sur la la la la la l'opéra le répertoire
se faisait et fait la connaissance
d'auteur et puis je prenais un peu un
peu n'importe quoi je me faisais un
répertoire à moi sans aucune directive
et m'est arrivé dans l'histoire
or le ciel valises et d'aiguillage